uh
uh hey good for you huh yeah a Critics
Choice Award that you have actually got
invited to or we we got invited to it we
won you won nominated M1 we won
what was well wait no we're trying to
explain a Critics Choice Award you you
become the critic's choice that's how
they announce it they say and the
critic's choice is what it's what's the
cataracts best documentary what best
sports documentary
best sports in the world
is it in the world
I don't know
I'll say there was there were there was
a few that were not English language
so maybe yeah there was one French one
there was one that was mostly in
Russian but that was made by an
English-speaking filmmaker well then
there you go there's your answer one is
made by Peter Jackson he's not an
American
no
he's not he beat Peter Jackson no his
his movie was more about sport uh was
about music he did the The Beatles
documentary
which is terrific The Beatles being a
band
um yep from originally from Liverpool
they hit the scene in the 60s who
changed the world like music you know
what actually
yes okay that yes I have heard of them
yeah yeah no no you know what I realized
guys I did not I accidentally did not
grab a cut that cut that cut that mug I
grabbed a David Hornsby original yeah it
was the original yeah
that's uh that's Kanye yeah yeah riding
on the back of that prescient very
prescient yeah because he did this
this was basically just like a summary
of 2020. yes 2020. this is really it's
really a talented artist it's very
talented he's also very territorial of
his coffee mugs there was a big mug for
a while in the Mythic Quest offices that
just said in bold letters this bug
belongs to David Hornsby now what is
that is that because he doesn't like
other people's lips uh touching the
things that you know what I mean like is
it that is it like a cleanliness that
it's like that's his favorite mug to
drink out of and it's like I never
somebody grabs it I brought it because I
like to drink my coffee out of it so
much and someone else keeps using it
yeah
so maybe he's very particular about the
size of mug
anything out of a mug
uh no what would he be drinking out of a
mug he's not a coffee drinker right
he's been drinking energy drinks
recently I know he's rocks and her he's
been drinking the Rocks energy drinks he
sees the Rock and he's like that's what
I aspire to
you know clearly based on how he has
transformed um
he's not doing much towards that uh
there's always one energy drink away
from being the rock so thank you I wish
you had stuck with just one energy he's
always one energy away it does seem
petrified right that's a rock sort of
thing
very good I don't know Hey listen so
we've been we've been breaking stories
all day yeah yeah
I do feel guilty I'm gonna admit that to
you guys and to the audience
tell the audience what you did to us
I've been out of the writer's room for a
full day and a half
um two days effectively effectively two
days what time did you guys get in there
today ten uh I was there by 8 30 in the
morning oh all right so yeah almost a
full day uh so I've missed almost two
days
um I had to do some traveling for this
other show that I do
um so I want to say that I first off I
appreciate you all for first for putting
in the work
um and all I can do is promise you that
when I go when I get back in there I'm
gonna do my best you know what the worst
part is
I didn't even notice you were gone
was it more was it more pleasurable or
was it just sort of smoother just sort
of like everything just felt easier
smoother less volatile
the ideas were better ideas were better
you didn't have that thing constantly
where you're like you you keep hearing
this terrible idea and you have to like
redirect the room right and you hold the
side that it's coming from gets tense
somebody putting in the no butts yeah no
very untrue very interesting it's always
great to have you yeah you know what
it's like you know what it's like being
in that room it's hard yeah yeah well
and I think we're I think we're just
getting warmed up too right we're we're
getting warmed up it takes a second
right story is always the hardest now
did you guys break a story that was the
plan you were gonna yeah
mid-story amazing we have a loose a very
loose yeah very loose break that uh I
think it'd be great to have fresh eyes
and dig in and flesh out some more but
um we do have a lot of good ideas so we
haven't really talked about the the room
yet on the podcast yeah for this most
recent season we have a lot of note
cards out there a lot of really great
ideas true
um more than I thought we were gonna
have
um if I'm honest
um I was I I went home after that first
day or maybe it was after the second day
the bus just kind of blue skying and uh
I told Jill I was like I I think we
think we've got some really good ideas
this this I feel like we felt fresh this
year because it's been a minute since
we've all been in the room so is that
what it was maybe a little fresher it's
a nice room like the room itself is like
a big old window and it feels like um
[Laughter]
this episode Extreme Home Makeover oh my
god well this this episode's crazy so it
is crazy so I set us up with some
information yeah sure okay season four
episode 12 The Gang gets Extreme Home
Makeover Edition aired on November 13th
2008 was written by Charlie Glenn and
David and directed by Fred Savage in
this episode The Gang realizes they must
help others to achieve their dreams so
they redecorate a poor family's home a
la Extreme Makeover home Edition the
only problem is that the family is not
in on the plan
that's part of the excitement of it it's
being thrust into a situation where
you're like we're gonna you know we're
gonna change the thing with the show
that people were surprised they didn't
know they were going to get a homemade
renovation and then they surprised these
families by basically like doing it like
there's a lot of energy out of town be
like hey I'm gonna you're gonna go visit
your grandma and they come back and be
like look at your new home or yeah your
kids say they know at all I think they
must have said something else they don't
surprise them in the middle of the night
by screaming and dragging them from the
trash bags
orange family
[Music]
my brown friend it's time to change your
life yeah
all right that's cool that's cool I
guess
the way that was shot was like insane
did I was yeah we shot it at a high
frame rate high frame rate yeah did the
episode did the idea come out of the
idea of
instead of a home makeover you're doing
a home invasion like because that's what
it felt like that scene felt like a home
invasion like a scary home invasion you
know it was it was it was it was based
on you know the idea of wanting to do an
extreme home makeover episode but doing
it in the most wrong an extreme possible
way like really latching onto the
extreme aspect of it that would be a
slower frame rate right to create a
Steppy field no no you got to shoot at a
higher frame rates
oh I see what you're saying [ __ ] we did
whatever Steven Spielberg did when he
shot on the beaches of Normandy yeah hi
okay our DP everybody this is our DP
Sarah
um so like the shutter angle is smaller
so less light comes in so you don't get
like the sort of natural motion of blur
that you get with your regular like 24
or 23 frames per second that's what
makes it that weird yeah that effect
you're talking about the beach is
normally where it's like yeah yeah great
okay thank you good to know Sarah here's
what I was trying to remember watching
it now I remember some of this was done
in Philly in Kensington yes some of it
was done in La yep but the interior of
the house that we're like wrecking and
breaking la
where was that stage
yeah right right and we didn't we
definitely didn't bring the family to
Philadelphia so like that final reveal
shot is two different two different oh
we shot right we shot one side in L.A
and the others yep
it was easier to get a matching bus
again to bring the family there yes so
yeah because you know we pay for a hotel
room and but you know it's so funny like
there are parts of this episode they're
a little clunky like the vision board
explanation of why we're doing what
we're doing and then there are parts
that are just so damn funny because
they're just basic jokes about you
wearing shorts so that's the funniest
sequence and one of the funnest scenes I
think in the history of the show I do
remember us talking about that obviously
that was a choice we made in the
writer's room that was not an improvised
scene although there is um improvisation
happening in that in the take but
how did I think you're just laughing
about the funny difference between
cut-offs and those that look of the
cutoff shorts and the versus US yeah
jean shorts yeah but but the the whole
like wide spread thing like what was was
that based on the fact that that did I
do something like that in the room and
we were like oh we should do that on the
show like what I don't know I don't
remember we tried to justify why you
were wearing them I don't know I really
don't know
my favorite is that you say it's you
can't go lower because you're shorts and
your hips
yeah but but the point is your shorts
aren't preventing you from doing what
you need to do it's really funny right
so that whole scene
is just about the shorts does something
else happen well it's about the tool
belt initially I think about gets stolen
you want to watch it no but it's before
I'd like to watch it again yeah sure but
I as no it's us putting on the tool belt
and then and and me explaining the tool
belt and then you saying like that's
great but I want to talk about these
shorts all right let me ask you a
question then how can I give that
awesome Fray on your shorts wow
that sir is because you purchased blue
jean shorts
so this is where this is where it all
works for me but now the whole scene is
not even about jean shorts or Home
Makeovers it's about Dennis yes wanting
to teach Charlie something right and to
be helpful yeah because you've got
information that you were hoping to to
God he asked you about because you want
to share this information with him well
you learn things throughout the course
of your life right you take in certain
lessons you have certain experiences
where you and you build upon them
hopefully to build a better life for
yourself and I've built a better uh life
for myself when it comes to shorts
because of the knowledge that I have
about the difference between cutting
them yourself well versus buying and I'm
excited to share that with some with my
friend who also stands to now have a
better life so this is a great example
of an actor it's it's so the scene is so
stupid the joke is so stupid but it's an
actor making a choice that's very
specific right where you're saying okay
in my head I'm the way I'm going to
perform this is I really I was hoping he
would ask me this so that I can deliver
this information in a way that really
informs him so that when so he can have
he can enjoy this as well yeah probably
I do wind up doing a few seasons later
yes
that Dennis told me about the shorts
yeah that's why I haven't yeah that's
right
why did you cut them so hot right I
thought you might ask that see it limits
restriction of life
take a wide stance take the widest dance
thing possibly can okay leg movement
this is uh if I'm going wide and I'm
being honest with you I'm maxing out
about here that's not bad
you can check this out you don't want to
make them feel bad
yeah anymore that's it but that's pretty
cool
but the shorts aren't preventing me from
doing what I need to do can you pause it
again
now I do remember talking about you're
getting you're not getting a high ride
he said no I'm getting a high ride yeah
and Chad's laughing like look here he's
yeah yeah how can it not happen right
right he's laughing but the character
could be too yeah now why what is that
movement what this why are you doing
that well because because when we were
shooting
um little David oh yeah yeah yeah I
don't think I did that on purpose but I
do remember when we were shooting it we
were like
it's something about having just weird
arm movements just made it funnier just
like having a kind of a strange posture
and doing strange things with my arms so
I think we were just kind of
experimenting with
us it was so hard to write because you
you pass over very quickly that you need
to be able to take a wider stance to
work more efficiently which doesn't make
sense but it doesn't matter because you
just blow past it and like get to that I
can't remember is there something in
this that happens I can explain that
moves the story forward or not I can't
find out
they're holding you back man well that
in your hips but I gotta tell you the
shorts aren't helping this is this
really all good [ __ ] this is like
bubbles right so what are you gonna do
next it's the discovery oh that's what
we're gonna do next Charlie grabbing
that propane torch I'm gonna burn the
wall oh you know what let's go at it
with the Wrecking Ball for a little
while it'll be more extreme and kind of
awesome okay all right so so the scene
is about establishing that he has a
freaking torch and that he's going to
try these controlled Burns uh well yeah
and Frank's recording which is and that
Frank's recording it which is leading
towards that the house is going to burn
down but we you know we have a little
bit of a runner that we thought in the
writer's room about these jean shorts
and it winds up becoming the entire the
whole thing and then it comes back at
the end because you're like well how are
we gonna end the scene well just yeah
well but also but but also like the
Ridiculousness of that conversation
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'd like to see now how old are you here
probably uh 2008 so 32 32. now how low
can you go now can we see can we change
your jeans these jeans are a little
tight for that pop them off
we got any of those separate things
shorts
and then you send us a video later yeah
maybe I'll Jill shoot a video
it's been 14 years since we shot the
Extreme Home Makeover episode back in
2008 and uh
we're gonna see how low I can go 14
years later because I haven't tested it
in a really long time I have no idea but
uh you know I got something better than
cut off jean shorts today I got my
priorities on so these are not going to
restrict me from doing what I need to do
all right so here we go see how it okay
you know
I don't think I can go any lower than
that otherwise I think I'm seriously
gonna hurt myself but that's pretty low
that's pretty love
it's weird because I'm not flexible but
I've always been flexible that way I
mean not flexible by some people's
standards but bye it used to go lower
that's pretty damn okay I don't think
I've never been that it's pretty
flexible yeah so my takeaway from this
episode is like uh some of it works some
of it doesn't but that scene is
perfection you've had like a couple of
iconic uh moments and that kind of makes
up for all the rest of it yeah uh even
D's broken Spanish is very funny yeah
somebody took a couple years of Spanish
in high school awesome okay you remember
all right tell them um to relax first
off because they look a little tense and
then uh we're gonna build them a new
house and a new life just like on
Extreme Makeover on TV okay okay Juarez
is say a fast deal extremos
Como LA televisione
see
[Music]
let's see I see they get it I still got
it somos yes
America
notice from my re-watch that Retta is in
this episode Retta yeah yeah yes and how
did you guys know her
I
mean I think yeah
Justin and was really funny he hired her
and she was really funny yeah like
someone that talented comes in and
they're starting they're probably early
I'm assuming it's pretty early in her
career uh and you know it's like a
no-brainer you're like okay she makes
the scene way better yeah even her just
Stephen looks to us as we're discussing
that's why we put so many of them in
yeah because her looks were great
holding on you guys and then she watches
you clearly Force somebody into opening
a credit card and does it anyway it's
like it's not her problem it's not it's
yeah it's not yeah I think a lot of this
had to do with us watching Apocalypto
and loving it because it's a great movie
but then talking about it and talking
about very specifically that ending the
ending to the movie and we were in The
Writer's room where we're like that's a
pretty [ __ ] up ending and then there
was a lot of there was a lot of back and
forth as to well there were different
interpretations there was different
interpretations there was the right one
and the wrong one well you had the
interpretation that that it was what's
in the description in the episode right
I never watched it either oh it's so
good but what's the end that well after
the main character right goes through
the most harrowing experience uh there's
a shot of like these Spanish Ships
coming and uh
just to set it up even more the whole
movie is about how this one guy is about
to be sacrificed there was like
sacrificing slaves to the Sun God and
then he was just about to be sacrificed
um and there was an eclipse and people
thought that it was like God speaking to
them anyway he escaped and he spends the
whole movie trying to escape from his
his captors who are just trying to
execute him and it's really just like
riveting the entire thing but then the
final shot is he like finally escapes
and he gets to the edge of this cliff
and he looks out and you see these
European Ships coming in so there's two
interpretations I think I think I think
the other one's valid but I don't think
it's true knowing what we know about
Melanie my right sure yeah my uh initial
takeaway seeing that was like oh the the
death and destruction is still coming
yeah the bigger danger bigger and more
danger and you are living in Apocalypto
existence which is that's valid that's
fair like and I remember you you saying
that I was like oh right that's not the
why the way I interpreted it but that'd
be interesting
um I think based on Mel and Mel's
beliefs and his and in your long
friendship with him and yeah of course
like sitting down having coffee and
discussing it yeah but he's he's like a
staunch Catholic hardcore Catholic and
believes in and and and if I recall
correctly we'll have to look at that
final shot that I think those ships had
like crosses on them I believe if not
the implication is there that they
brought Christianity
to that part of the world and and sure
and cl and colonize that region and
wiped out most of the culture and people
and I believe what the movie was saying
was don't worry everybody
it's all about to get better
but there's gonna have to be some
[ __ ] that goes down first a lot of you
are gonna yeah perish we're gonna teach
you a religion that doesn't sacrifice
people but in order to make sure that
you learn it we have to kill lots we're
gonna have to slaughter the ones who get
in our way directly and indirectly with
disease
[Music]
the Always Sunny podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp oh Charlie Day Here Local
podcaster and brain Enthusiast is your
brain making too much noise all the time
are your intrusive thoughts constantly
rattling around driving you crazy
are they crying at your productivities
and livelihoods think there's no answer
you're so stupid there is better help
that's great uh
therapy is great you know as the world's
largest therapy Service uh better help
has matched three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus you
know what's great about it
it's affordable you just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler in a
waiting room no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save ten percent off your first
month
at betterhelp.com Sunny that's
betterhelp help.com
slash sunny
as the holidays approach we are
sponsored in part by manscape guys it's
never too early to start thinking about
holiday gifts whether they're for
friends or for the friends in your pants
it depends on your pants you mean like
your car keys or house keys or I think
he meant uh
testicles you can make this a season to
be jolly with manscaped I mean that's
right do your little drummer boy a favor
and use the lawnmower 4.0 to avoid
another silent night in the bedroom then
add in manscapes top of the line shower
products to have people thinking all I
want for Christmas is you I can tell you
right now that this gift package is a
gift for your package and you won't find
a better boost of confidence under the
tree this year than how your penis looks
Santa cares about his sack so should you
look nice when you get naughty and get
free shipping and 20 by going to
manscape.com Sunny yeah that's right get
20 off and free shipping at
manscaped.com Sunny that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscapes.com Sunny
manscaped get your jingle balls ready
for the holidays
[Music]
in this episode the Mac envisions
impregnating Danica Patrick while
getting drunk in the Sahara desert on a
dune buggy yeah
there's a lot of naked dudes on that
vision board too are there yeah there's
buff well there's buff dudes and oh well
that's how he envisions all right at the
time that was how he was envisioning
himself so yeah he's the buff dude in
that scenario yeah
but uh yeah upon further reflection it
could very well be a what he aspires to
we're looking up Danica Patrick where is
she known from she's a race she's a race
car race car
drivers I don't I don't pay attention to
sports
now why is it you cannot like do people
race cars until they're very very old or
is that something like like any other
sport where you're like well after a
certain age
well I mean once you're yeah when your
reflexes start to slow down you know
yeah I think it becomes more difficult
to compete at a certain level but yeah
do they have like a senior Senior Tour
you know like probably do yeah it seems
pretty dangerous but I think they go I
think they go as long as they as long as
they can but there's a reason why you
know uh I believe you know my dad was an
airline pilot and he I believe
at the time they they had to retire by
60 they couldn't work past the age of 60
but now I think they've increased it to
65 I think they pushed it to 65 now
which seems which seems right
um you know because if you can pass the
physical and living longer at healthier
lives right she's an individual she
competed at the 2018 Daytona 500
um and the Indianapolis 500 before
officially retiring in 2018. ah so she
she did try at the tender age of
well now she is 40 so I guess she was
36 then that's something why why can't
you keep driving at 40. did you guys
have do you guys have weird experiences
in your 40s where like
certain that a thing we were in Joshua
Tree this weekend and uh we were we were
climbing rocks and doing that whole
thing and I had a couple of moments
where I just like was like
I shouldn't be doing this you know and
when I was younger I mean I was a monkey
I would climb anything like I I was
fearless and
always felt very coordinated and had
good like peripheral vision and
it was not hard for me to sort of
navigate very you know uneven terrain or
whatever I was on some of these rocks
and I was and I was like I'm gonna fall
I'm gonna kill myself I'm gonna die if
I'm you know what I mean I was like that
man I was like [ __ ] I don't want to get
I don't want to get to that place where
I feel yeah like it's just like that's
biochemical man is this your body being
like nah nah I don't want to be on
slippery rocks at any age they're not
slippery that's the thing about the very
respiratory they're extremely grippy I
don't know if you've done much climbing
Joshua Tree well let me ask you this did
you wear a helmet and did you have your
kids wear a helmet no yeah so this is
this is what killed I don't know
anybody know I know climbing and talking
about like a little pilot room no you're
scrambling up some serious wow I mean we
weren't quite doing that but we were we
were in situations where you know what
actually this is what I said to Jill I I
actually don't think
and I'm not totally sure about this but
but what it actually felt to me like as
I was getting dizzy
but I don't think it was actually
because I was worried about myself
following falling it was because I
didn't feel like I could fully
concentrate on what I was doing because
I was afraid my kids were gonna fall
yeah and that was making me like
disoriented and dizzy because I was like
so scared that like my kids were gonna
slip and yeah I never I wouldn't even
think yeah and we so they said like
number one wear a goddamn helmet like
how many like head injuries you're so
right and we had helmets too because we
had the kids here but here's the here
okay this is a true parenting concern
and I would love to hear what the what
the creeps and listeners think about
this because I don't know what the
answer is because I think I don't know
if I did the right thing or the wrong
thing
my kid Axel was super we went to Joshua
Tree and he just like fell in love he
for whatever reason just took to
scrambling up those rocks yeah he found
a group of kids and they just love it
and it's so fun
and and so he did it with this whole
first day and he had an absolute blast
and I I went to bed and I was texting
with a friend of mine who's a rock
climber like a legit rock climber and I
just said I had the most amazing time
with my kid and he's like did he wear a
helmet and I said no he said absolutely
do not let him do that again without
wearing a helmet because there's so many
head injuries it's so common and people
die all the time so the next day I got
him a helmet and I was like put on the
helmet he's like I'm not wearing the
helmet I'm not wearing the helmet I'm
like you have to wear the helmet I'm not
letting you climb up that rock unless
you wear that helmet
puts on the helmet goes up with a bunch
of kids who weren't wearing helmets
because I can't control the kids and I
don't know what was said or even if
anything was said but he was like
humiliated by the whole thing yeah
hasn't gone back since
won't do it he's just like I won't do it
I won't do it and and I get it yeah
totally so what do you do you want to be
the one nerd in the helmet
kids don't have kids that's one answer
yeah I have it that's one answer that's
fair that's good yeah
um I mean I rode my bike everywhere I
never wore a helmet man no I don't need
this guy as a kid no
Gotta Wear a Helmet you should wear a
helmet Caitlyn almost died when she was
a kid on a bike accident I know but if
you die you die
yeah that's callous well that's easy no
no but if you die you die that's on you
like you you can make it but it's a kid
yeah that's uh yeah no it's looking
uncool in front of your friends is worse
than that I agree with that age and so
they shouldn't be responsible for but as
a parent how do you weigh those things
well do I want my kid to not look cool
or do I want them to listen well the
answer is I want to live but now I've
taken away his passion for something
yeah yeah I mean look I I think I think
the the problem is like I mean if when
you go snowboarding or skiing or
whatever you know
90 of the people are wearing now helmets
now it's hit critical mass yes because
so many people were [ __ ] dying yeah
yeah yeah yeah well in popular culture
yes you just keep bringing him back and
like no we're going back to the place
that you really enjoyed and you're
climbing and you're climbing and you're
wearing a helmet you're climbing nerd
you're climbing with your nerd helmet on
that's right and if someone calls you a
nerd you know what you do you beat the
[ __ ] out of it you know what you don't
want to push them down the Rock and
they're not wearing a helmet
may have done that I did that I did that
one it worked yeah
maybe you can have them lean into it
wear like a full Evil Knievel outfit
yeah you know what I mean so it actually
looks cool so it looks like he's doing
it on purpose yeah with a [ __ ] cow
okay hell yeah I have a question for you
are you exhibiting a similar Behavior to
him of always wearing protective gear
when you do dangerous things I did I
wore I wore a helmet like to show
solidarity and then he was like well now
my dad's a door too oh that's and I was
like dude trust me I'm not a dork ask
anybody here ask anybody here he's like
Dad you're the [ __ ] worst thing I
know Daddy you're the [ __ ] worst he
didn't say that but I inferred it they
didn't have a problem on that we took
him snowboarding and skiing that no
problem because everybody else was
because that that's what I was gonna say
yeah you know if everybody at Joshua
Tree was climbing rocks and wearing
helmets wouldn't be an issue would it uh
but you're absolutely right we I mean no
not a single person that I saw but you
scrambling rocks who was uh was wearing
a helmet so it didn't even occur to me I
don't know why
do you guys do any Charlie you said you
rode bikes without helmets did you do
any extreme things when you were younger
that looking back on it it's like how
did I ever survive that thing yeah so
many stupid tons yeah but it was a
different time climbing climbing it was
a lot more dangerous
no you know like barefoot no definitely
no helmet yeah it's just a dumb [ __ ]
like on acid yeah you need a lot have
been doing a lot of stupid things stupid
stuff it is stupid yes
have you ever done any home renovation
stuffs have you uh swung a sledgehammer
or knocked down a wall like my
but his dad uh used to have these like
Apartments uh in Newport Rhode Island
and um he gave me a job one summer uh
repainting them and this guy
puts a ladder up three stories high
right so the first floor is second floor
third floor he ties the ladder into like
fire escape and he's like uh this guy Mr
Merkel who's like a drill sergeant in
the Army like a principal awesome guy I
love him great family here my car
control you're gonna go up that ladder
and just scrape the paint off the top of
the roof now to get to the top of the
roof you had to stand at the top of the
ladder on one toe so he was one toe with
his body pressed against a building
three stories up we weren't wearing
[ __ ] helmets just scrape it away just
scrape and paint off this room imagine
also not wearing masks or I no no no
just all the dust and pain like just
breathing it in it happens if you fall
he's like grab the ladder because the
ladder will fall but then it'll hit the
fire escape and you won't go all the way
to the ground
you got it Mr Merkel yes sir yes sir Mr
murder uh and I just I Juarez that house
I mean it was the worst paint job ever
and he had to redo it it was like really
secure life for no reason at all then
yeah
you know it's a good four dollars
I mean I I my my buddy uh Mark Dunlap
and I uh had a job once when we were 18
years old uh
working at a factory
and like doing stuff we had no business
doing it like I I didn't have any kind
of a licensed I don't know if you need
maybe do you need a license to drive a
forklift any kind of Alabama
I doubt it
I mean it's a good point right right it
seems like you guys just did whatever
the [ __ ] you wanted down there
you know what because there's a lot of
freedom now yeah yeah a lot of [ __ ]
Freedom down there uh but yeah driving
forklifts and you know working with like
toxic materials and like having to wear
like gas masks to to because there's all
kinds of toxic dust and [ __ ] like so
many areas that were like flammable we
were fixing machines that we didn't even
know what they were or how to fix them
we were I was like what is this and
getting paid 525 an hour if I remember I
I remember because it was a dollar over
minimum wage which at the time was 425
at least in in Alabama it was I think
that was the federal minimum wage I wish
I wish I knew how to do more of it like
uh you know on my handyman stuff yeah
one of my closest friends Chris like is
you know as a construction company in
Rhode Island and uh Paddock construction
if you want a good job done in Rhode
Island but like you know he knows how to
like go ahead and build a deck or an
entire house or redo your kitchen like
what an awesome thing to also like to
know how to do the balls on on the
characters of of Dennis and Charlie to
think they can just renovate at home
they don't know [ __ ] they don't know
anything about what they're doing they
just start breaking the place and then
yeah so the show was called the original
show was called Extreme Home the Extreme
Makeover and then and that was about
that was a show where they would take
somebody and carve them up and give them
plastic surgery and whatnot no there's
one you're thinking of the Swan oh well
they turn you from Monopoly duckling
into a swan via plastic surgery amazing
looking up Extreme Makeover depicts
ordinary men and women undergoing
extreme makeovers involving plastic
surgery exercise regimen's hairdressers
otherwise it ain't extreme if it's just
a little makeup and hairspray added a
home element to it and then they just
yeah they I did the Home Makeover thing
um and it's hard it's hard to explain to
the anybody who would say watch this
episode now a young person watching this
episode now that would think oh this is
they're talking about some show that
exists or maybe they're making it up or
whatever when those kinds of shows would
come out they would be Smash Hits and
you couldn't get away from them they
would be there wasn't as many channels
there was no streaming it was and if
there was a hit on ABC it was massive
and that guy Ty Pennington like you you
would see him at like a TV events and he
would be the star that was there and you
would think well this guy's career is
just like never gonna it's he's gonna be
Ty Pennington for the rest of his life
and he is well he is going to be Ty
Pennington I was talking about that with
the show where it was like you took
someone's like
one story one bedroom house and turn it
into a five bedroom story house are they
going to have to pay a crazy new tax
bracket because the house is valued at a
different uh like how's that work that
has not work no
taxes and money work you want another
[ __ ]
I do remember watching that show and and
thinking it was so funny how they would
you know they'd be talking to the kid
and the kid would be like you know like
what are you into you know what's Little
Johnny into you know oh he really likes
sharks oh sharks huh okay
and then you know they would do the
makeover and the house would be you know
classy for the most part and then you'd
go in the kids room and it was just like
and it's a shark bed and there's shark
posters everywhere and there's a fish
and there's a you know a giant poster of
sharks and it was just like okay I mean
he said he liked sharks and think he
yeah he's insane and then like uh you
know five years he's gonna be 15 and
we're gonna have to do all this [ __ ] in
like five minutes he's gonna be on to
something else right it's like yeah he
made the whole thing about sharks you
know my kid's sleeping in a shark's
mouth who wants to do that like so that
was that was and we never we didn't
quite we weren't able to do the taco bed
wound up yeah so I know somebody that
well I won't say his name because it'll
it'll betray his trust but we all know
him and he worked on he worked in some
of these kinds of shows and he said the
biggest moment the whole episode was
based on the reveal
the whole episode is based on the real
so no matter what happens if you don't
get the right reveal you don't have a
show so knowing that the producers would
do all sorts of [ __ ] up things they
wanted people to cry really more than
anything so they would keep them awake
like they would purposefully like
keep them awake for 48 hours 48 hours to
make them emotionally unstable
which I guess would work where they
would but they would hide it like they
would put them in a hotel and they'd be
like you're going to this party and then
we're going to go out and here's a bunch
of alcohol and then they would like come
and wake them up at like in the middle
of the night and be like we gotta do
this one thing and then go back and then
wake them up like really [ __ ] with them
and then when they showed up they would
be emotionally drained and then they
would see they would have the reveal and
so not that different from what we do on
the show except they at the end of the
day they've got a nice house instead of
a burned down
we were satirizing lots of things in
this in this episode I believe including
those shows there's a good bit in this
episode that I'd like to bring up too
where Dennis is comforting Charlie and
you do a little bit of like do you
remember that part where you're like I'm
upset about Sears yeah and you start
massaging his shoulders and then you
give them a nice little hug at the end
yeah sweet little moment
just breathe for me feel what I'm doing
yeah dude I just
I'm sorry bro but I get very passionate
about Sears I mean extreme homemade I
mean what
helping people helping people
come here
I do actually remember I was I was doing
the massage thing and I gave you the hug
and I was like this is nice it's like
you were very warm and like good side
like good hugging size
um yeah like the whole thing with that
was like the episodes were always like
about Sears it was like so much about
Sears why it was about them yeah about
the yeah kind of helping a family but
really it's just like one long
commercial for Sears yeah but I love
that you always say it Sears doesn't get
anything out of it yeah fundamentally
misunderstanding why they mentioned it
all the time I feel like that was at the
very beginning where we're like wow
they're like just like putting this
advertising right in the middle of the
content which of course now is just all
about anything and speaking of let's go
to commercial
[Applause]
guys we're supported by athletic Greens
in their delicious green powder ag1 a
product I use literally every day wait
mate are you using ag1 every day now
yeah wait are you yeah I've been using
ag1 wait did you know that it has 75
high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Foods Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to start your day right I
sure did Charlie listen I'm very happy
to hear that you're using it all the
time I mean it means we successfully
converted her with our expert
salesmanship but then do you guys
remember how I literally brought them to
you as a sponsor in the okay okay then
why don't you uh name a selling point
you love so much about athletic greens
and ag-1 yeah well there's less than one
gram of sugar that's pretty good and it
supports better sleep quality and Muscle
Recovery and you know all the things you
guys oh that's all the things that we
normally say the things we normally say
about we've been saying yeah yeah I mean
we got her yeah but do be like Meg and
start taking ag1 every day your body
will thank you all right to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com sunny again that is
athletic greens.com Sunny to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
all right guys let's be honest we could
all use a little more motivation when it
comes to working out and by that I mean
you know some competition Charlie what
kind of competition are you talking
about here I'm talking about fight Camp
interactive at home boxing they bring
the best workout in the world into your
home and they make it fun for any skill
level ah if I can't well you have
thousands of workouts led by expert
trainers with Decades of experience
teaching proper boxing form and
technique yeah that's right and and more
importantly you have live punch counting
stats that push you to meet your goals
each round you'll not only unlock
achievements so you can compete with
yourself but you know you can go head to
head with other members so you can
compete with anyone whether they're
across the living room or across the
country so join the biggest boxing
community in the world without leaving
your home all right this holiday season
you'll also get a a heart rate monitor
and a premium Jump Rope for free all
right that's an additional 148 dollar
value for free fight Camp packages start
at just 99 bucks they also also offers
some great financing options so you can
get started for as low as nine dollars a
month to get started and to get your
free gifts with purchase go to
fightcamp.com Sunny that's fightcamp.com
Sunny
[Music]
you guys believe in manifesting do you
think that there's anything the secret
and if you I do yeah I do but I don't
think it says woo-woo as I think the
general public yeah I think I think if
you're saying having a goal yeah you
know having a goal and positive thoughts
yeah I think it affects it right I think
people pick up on your energy and I
think when you put something out into
the world you're putting a certain
energy out and people pick up on it it
affects how you approach your work it
affects how you approach your goals you
know and I think so I think there's
probably some very like tangible science
behind it as opposed to it just being
totally woo but
uh I feel like
uh manifesting things absolutely
absolutely works I mean I try to get on
your show for eight years it took me of
manifesting that did you did you send
him you did it I did it well the direct
link was that I talked about it all the
time and I talked about it to somebody
who was on your show who then went and
was like this chick's obsessive thing
like why don't you guys interview her
that was Scott martyr but I wrote my
spec script that got me my first job was
a sunny specs so I was manifesting it
have we have I read that spell oh God no
you're not going to either no no no what
if we produced it now what if we use it
the season what if I were to tell you
you know we got nothing so what if we
did an entire season of Television where
we just did people's spec scripts that
they send sent in finally The Bar Rescue
episode The Bar Rescue episode is a lock
I think what we've learned today is
don't do a podcast at the end of the day
after breaking stories
tough on the energy but
good content in there some interesting
conversations look at me you know if
people want to see the real us they're
every once in a while they're going to
get a podcast that was filmed at the end
of the day and the energy is going to be
maybe slightly different and you know
maybe that's uh we didn't complain
no no I'm on a different time zone I'm
three hours it's three hours later but I
haven't really been adjusted to the time
zone that quickly and we're gone that
long
no but I did get up early and I was I
was on a six hour flight but I'm not
complaining it's all good no I've got I
got a great life get to spend it with my
friends
you know we've established if you want
to complain you can yeah I don't really
feel like complaining I feel very happy
I feel very fortunate no I feel good too
do you feel like uh overall you you walk
around life uh with a general sense of
gratitude I try to yeah yeah so you
aspire to that you know you don't feel
like that's your default but you asleep
I'm happy all the time about everything
but I'm not happy not happy yeah great
gratitude yes
um but you know you only really like
appreciate how good you have it when
stuff starts going like badly so like
during the pandemic and stuff I found a
lot more gratitude about my life and
just like yeah just I would say I found
more gratitude about my non-work life uh
which I'd always thought sucked I always
love have tons of gratitude for my work
life because I get to do really fun
things and that's cool but then I was
like you know it's great just like going
for a walk or like just hanging out with
some friends and like you start being
more gracious about more grateful about
stuff like that so I would say yeah I'm
happy to be back in the room with you
guys right now Rob said he noticed I was
in a good mood the other day I did I I
noticed you seem very happy yeah I am
very happy recently I'm having a lot of
fun in the writer's room really enjoying
it yeah it's a blast it has been fun um
we have now completed watching all our
episodes of season four oh this is we
are going to error I think the night man
one last we'll we'll air that one last
but we don't have a conversation about
season four as a whole during that
that's true yeah what are your thoughts
four was strong I I like I like it but
to be honest for my money the show
becomes
I think what I love about it the most in
season five
things
don't really need like realizing oh we
don't need these aspects of Storytelling
to break one of these stories a lot of
justification a lot of justification we
don't need and just be like no we're
just like the characters are just doing
things yeah and the audience will go
with it starting season five yeah yeah I
think I think we I think we just it was
the first year that I feel like we
really dialed it in and you know sort of
took what was working
um from all the first four seasons and
combined it all into one show
um there's some pretty classic episodes
I've said this before in the podcast but
my favorite is the gang gives Frank an
intervention and that is in season five
so that is in season five yeah great
episode guys